sabe todo sobre demostraciones de fuerza
el primer ministro húngaro viktor orbán
es el campeón de las grandes
concentraciones
y de las ofensivas de encanto
para estas elecciones parlamentarias al
líder del partido nacionalista
conservador que se presenta a un cuarto
mandato no presentó un programa
electoral sino regalos financieros el
precio de la gasolina y de varios
alimentos básicos ha congelado para
suavizar la infracción medidas que
benefician a los pensionados el corazón
de su electorado buscó obtuvo todo
hombre conseguimos un tercer mes de
pensión el apoyo a las generaciones más
jóvenes estamos muy contentos con
nuestra situación económica pero en un
país en el que la gran mayoría de los
medios de comunicación están amordazados
por el gobierno sólo unos pocos
periodistas como los del canal partizán
se resisten a la máquina de propaganda y
la gente se ha desilusionado con la
política y se está volviendo a política
no porque sean estúpidos o les hayan
lavado el cerebro no sino porque piensan
y ven que ya no hay un debate racional y
justo en este país
a pocos días de las elecciones los
sondeos pronostican un resultado
ajustado pero más favorable al partido
de viktor orbán que se enfrenta a una
colisión de varios partidos de la
oposición estos jóvenes estudiantes que
votan por primera vez están divididos
como la sociedad húngara entre el deseo
de estabilidad y la esperanza de cambio
y creo que muchos jóvenes de nuestra
edad quieren por fin tener un nuevo
gobierno es fedap aouate porque están
hartos de lo que han hecho con la
sociedad civil y las minorías
verdi frank gehry tips más que nunca
estas elecciones legislativas en hungría
sean también un referéndum a favor o en
contra de víctor a